cinéma maintenant avec la sortie
mercredi du dernier tim burton sweeney
todd se son titre l'histoire d'un
diabolique barbier londonien incarné par
johnny depp qui épris de vengeance ne
rase et plus les joues mais trancher les
gorges un film tiré d'une comédie
musicale à succès de broadway
emmanuel lambert londres 19e siècle une
femme un bébé
la vie était belle pour benjamines
barker mais un juge en vieux décida de
le déporter à vie pour voler sa famille
le seigneur prénom votre âne en pitié
quinze ans plus tard le barde il revient
dans le quartier de fleet street pour se
venger
le barca n'est plus désormais il tient
la vengeance oui madame
c'est lui qui à notre avis
et ap
un film de tim burton est toujours un
événement cette fois ci le réalisateur a
adapté une comédie musicale ou plutôt un
opéra macabre datant de 1979
j'ai assisté à une représentation à
londres
quand j'étais étudiant ça m'a bluffé
j'ai adoré la musique l'histoire et
l'horreur ensemble j'ai trouvé ça
formidable
burton et johnny depp sixième film
ensemble
mais c'est la première fois que l'acteur
américain chante réellement à l'écran
alors avec une épouse chanteuse
forcément ils avaient un peu la pression
m
ouais
ouais c
vous savez je me demandais si je pouvais
y arriver sans décevoir ou mettre la
honte intime à mes enfants ou à vanessa
c'est clair on n'aurait pas pu choisir
une comédie musicale plus difficile
c'était pas évident ici les mots
reconnaissent une deuxième fin peu
ragoûtante sanglant gothique violent un
conseil écarter les enfants tim burton
est une nouvelle fois d'humeur macabre